hello and welcome to the CISSP
certification course offered by simply
learn certified information systems
security professional CISSP is an
autonomous information security
certification governed by the
international information systems
security certification consortium or is
c-square a CISSP is an information
assurance professional who defines the
architecture design management and/or
controls that assure the security of
business environments cissp was the
first credential in the field of
information to meet the stringent
requirements of iso/iec standard 17,000
24 CISSP is an objective measure of
excellence and a globally recognized
standard of achievement in June 2004 the
CISSP became the first information
security credential accredited by a NSI
iso/iec standard 17,000 24 2003
accreditation the objectives of this
domain will be discussed in the
following screen
after completing this domain you will be
able to define CISSP explain about is C
square list down the different CISSP
domains understand the need for CISSP
identify the various CISSP certification
requirements described at CISSP exam
CISSP expands to certified information
systems security professional the
various features of cissp are as follows
it is the first certification in
information security which is globally
recognized to certify the information
systems security professional CISSP is
an information assurance professional
who has demonstrated a globally
recognized level of competence provided
by a common body of knowledge that
defines the architecture design
management risk and controls that assure
the security of business environments
CISSP is a gold standard and
vendor-neutral
IT security certification the CISSP is
governed by the international
information system security
certification consortium or is c-square
the CISSP curriculum covers subject
matter in a variety of information
security topics the CISSP examination is
based on the common body of knowledge or
cbk the cbk is taxonomy a collection of
topics relevant to information security
professionals around the world in the
subsequent screen we will discuss the
international information systems
security certification consortium
incorporated in detail
is C square stands for international
information system security
certification consortium Incorporated
headquartered in the United States and
with offices in London Hong Kong and
Tokyo the International information
system security certification consortium
Incorporated is C square is the global
not-for-profit leader in educating and
certifying information security
professionals they are recognized for
gold standard certifications and
excellent education programs is C square
is comprised of a global team of top
information security professionals and
managed by professional staff who work
together with regional and topical
advisory boards to tackle any and all
new information security issues with
zeal is C square develops and maintains
the is C square C BK or the common body
of knowledge a compendium of information
security topics let us look at the
various domains in CISSP in the next
screen
the CISSP domains are drawn from various
information security topics within the
ISC square common body of knowledge or
cbk it is updated annually which
reflects the up-to-date best practices
worldwide in the domains the CISSP cbk
consists of the following 10 domains
information security governance and risk
management access control
telecommunications and network security
security architecture and design
physical or environmental security
software development security
cryptography business continuity and
disaster recovery planning legal
regulations investigations and
compliance and operations security
information security governance and risk
management is the identification of an
organization's information assets and
the development documentation and
implementation of policies standards
procedures and the guidelines
it covers security governance and policy
information classification ownership
contractual agreements and procurement
processes risk management concepts
personnel security security education
training and awareness and certification
and accreditation access control is a
collection of mechanisms that work
together to create security architecture
to protect the assets of the information
system it covers the fundamental
concepts of access control methodologies
or techniques effectiveness and access
control attacks telecommunications and
network security discusses network
structures transmission methods
transport formats and security measures
used to provide availability integrity
and confidentiality
it covers network architecture and
design communication channels network
components and network attacks security
architecture and design contains the
concepts principles structures and
standards used to design implement
monitor and secure operating systems
equip
it networks applications and those
controls use to enforce various levels
of confidentiality integrity and
availability
it covers fundamental concepts of
security models capabilities of
Information Systems countermeasure
principles and vulnerabilities and
threats
physical or environmental security
addresses the threats vulnerabilities
and countermeasures that can be utilized
to protect the enterprise's resources
and sensitive information physically it
covers site facility design
considerations perimeter security
internal security and facilities
security software development security
refers to the controls that are included
within systems and applications software
and the steps used in their development
it covers systems development lifecycle
or sdlc application environment and
security controls and effectiveness of
application security cryptography is the
principles means and methods of
disguising information to ensure its
integrity confidentiality and
authenticity
it covers encryption concepts digital
signatures cryptanalytic attacks public
key infrastructure or PKI and
information hiding alternatives business
continuity and disaster recovery
planning addresses the preservation of
the business in the face of major
disruptions to normal business
operations
it covers business impact analysis
recovery strategy disaster recovery
process and provide training legal
regulations investigations and
compliance addresses computer crime laws
and regulations
the investigative measures and
techniques which can be used to
determine if a crime has been committed
and the methods to gather evidence
it covers legal issues investigations
forensic procedures and compliance
requirements or procedures operation
security is used to identify the
controls over Hardware media and the
operators with access privileges to any
of these resources
it covers resource protection Incident
Response attack prevention and response
and patch and vulnerability management
let us discuss the benefits of the CISSP
for professionals in the following
screen
CISSP or certified information systems
security professional provides many
benefits for professionals the benefits
of CISSP for professionals are it helps
in demonstrating a working knowledge of
information security it ensures that the
professionals have commitment to
profession CISSP offers a career
differentiator with enhanced credibility
and marketability cissp provides the
exclusive benefits of valuable resources
such as peer networking and idea
exchange for is c-square members CISSP
indicates that certified information
security professionals earn a worldwide
average of 25 percent more than their
non certified counterparts according to
the global information security
workforce study it helps to fulfill
government and organization requirements
for information security certification
mandates in the next screen we will
discuss how CISSP is beneficial for
employers
cissp adds its benefits not only to the
professionals but also to the employers
the benefits of CISSP for employers are
as follows cissp improves the
credibility and value of the employees
in the organization to a higher rank as
the is c-square certifications are
recognized internationally it offers an
increased credibility and goodwill for
the organization when working with
vendors and contractors cissp empowers
the employees with the universal
language circumventing ambiguity with
industry accepted terms and practices it
validates the organization's commitment
and years of experience gained in the
industry it requires the continuing
professional education or CPE credits to
ensure that CISSP professionals improve
their skills CISSP satisfies
certification mandate requirements of
the organization when dealing with
service providers or subcontractors in
the following screen we will discuss
CISSP certification requirements
there are certain certification mandate
requirements to become a CISSP
professional they are as follows
obtain the required experience register
for the examination complete the
endorsement process maintain the CISSP
certification audit obtain the required
experience five years of direct
full-time professional security work
experience in two or more of the ten
domains of the is C square C is SP
common body of knowledge or CB K four
years of direct full-time professional
security work experience in two or more
of the ten domains of the CISSP c BK
with the four-year college degree or
additional credential from the ISC
square approved list in case of no
experience the candidates can become an
associate of is C square by successfully
passing the CISSP exam
he has six years to earn the required
experience to become a CISSP to register
for the examination register for the
exam by visiting is C square official
website click on the link for exam
registration create a user account and
then select Pearson VUE testing center
for scheduling the exam appear for the
exam on the scheduled date and pass the
exam complete the endorsement process
the candidate is required to subscribe
to the is C square code of ethics and
has to get the application endorsed
before the credential can be awarded an
endorsement form must be completed and
signed by an is e square certified
professional the professional should be
an active member and able to attest to
your professional experience the time
limit for the endorsement to become
certified is nine months from the date
of examination or become an associate of
is C square if the candidate does not
become certified or an associate of is C
square within nine months from the date
of examination he or she is required to
retake the exam in order to become
certified is C Square can act as an
endorser if the candidate is not able to
find a certified individual to act as
one please refer to the endorsement
assistance guidelines for additional
information about the endorsement
requirements
maintain the CISSP certification
recertification is required every three
years recertification is accomplished
through continuing professional
education or CPE a total of 120 credits
is required every three years a minimum
of twenty CPEs
must be posted during each year of the
three year certification cycle CIS SPS
must also pay an annual maintenance fee
of $85 per year audit candidates who
passed the examination will be randomly
selected and audited by is c-square
services prior to the issuance of any
certificate multiple certifications may
result in a candidate being audited more
than once under the following
circumstances and with appropriate
documentation candidates are eligible to
waive one year of professional
experience one year waiver of the
professional experience requirement
based on a candidate's education
candidates can substitute a maximum of
one year of direct full-time security
professional work experience the
substitution is possible only if the
candidate has a four-year college degree
or advanced degree in information
security from the US national center of
academic excellence in information
security CAE IAE or regional equivalent
one-year waiver of the professional
experience requirement for holding an
additional credential on the ISC Square
approved list the waiver is done if the
candidates have the following valid
experience and the information systems
security related work performed as a
practitioner auditor consultant
investigator or instructor that requires
information security knowledge and
involves the direct application of that
knowledge the five years of experience
must be the equivalent of actual
full-time information security work not
just information security
responsibilities for a five-year period
this requirement is cumulative however
and it may have been accrued over a much
longer period we will discuss cissp
examination and the next screen
the following are the important
information about CISSP examination
examination format the CISSP examination
consists of 250 multiple-choice
questions with 4 choices each 225
questions are graded 25 are not for
research purpose there may be scenario
based questions which may have more than
one multiple choice question associated
with it these questions will be
specifically identified in the test
booklet each of these exams contain 25
questions which are included for
research purposes only the research
questions are not specifically
identified there is no penalty for
guessing
so candidates should not leave any item
unanswered examination duration the
maximum duration of the CISSP exam is 6
hours
examination passing examination results
will be based only on the question
scored in the examination there are
several versions of the examination it
is important that each candidate has an
equal opportunity to pass the
examination no matter which version is
administered subject matter experts SMEs
have provided input for the difficulty
level of all questions used in the
examinations that information is used to
develop examination forms that have
comparable difficulty levels the passing
grade required is a scale score of 700
out of a possible 1,000 points on the
grading scale examination results for
computer-based testing or CBT based
exams the result is displayed once the
candidate submits his exam for
paper-based examination results will
normally be released via email within 4
to 6 weeks of the examination date a
comprehensive statistical and
psychometric analysis of the score data
is conducted prior to the release of
scores policy for retaking the exam via
CBI
after an unsuccessful attempt from the
date of the candidate's first exam
attempt candidates must wait 30 days to
retake the exam from the date of the
second attempt candidates must wait 90
days to retake the exam
from the date of a fourth attempt
candidates must wait 180 days from the
date of the third attempt to retake the
exam after this the cycle is repeated
examination fees the exam fee is u.s.
dollar 599 for both paper-based tests
and computer-based test examination type
from September 1st 2012 is c-square
offers only computer-based testing or
CBT for all of its certification exams
for candidates located in areas outside
of a 75 mile radius from an approved
testing center a case-by-case basis
paper-based exam is offered
hello and welcome to the domain on
information security governance and risk
management of the CISSP certification
course offered by simply learned
information security governance and risk
management involves the identification
of an organization's information assets
and the development documentation and
implementation of policies standards
procedures and guidelines that ensure
confidentiality integrity and
availability information security
governance and risk management is one of
the 10 domains of the common body of
knowledge cbk for the CISSP
certification exam this domain focuses
on risk analysis and mitigation it also
details security governance or the
organizational structure required for a
successful information security program
the objectives of this domain will be
listed in the following screen
after completing this domain you will be
able to recognize the importance of
information security management
recognize the importance of
confidentiality integrity and
availability which are the foundation
for information security list the types
of information classification describe
security policy implementation describe
information risk analysis and risk
management define the process of
managing personnel security and managing
security function
Kevin Butler is a security administrator
in the network firewalls division at
nutri Worldwide Inc he is preparing for
his CISSP exam
he started his preparation by reading a
historical case of a competitor of nutri
Worldwide Inc this competitor company
had failed to understand the importance
of information security the company had
planned their business continuity
strategy without continuous involvement
of IT only the IT security inputs were
taken without the team playing an active
role the business continuity planning or
BCP was weak in the areas of IT security
when the headquarters was hit by a
tornado there was a huge information
leak since data protection measures at
the time of a natural disaster were not
well planned for the IT tried their best
to prevent this the company had to face
losses that led them to filing for
bankruptcy within a few years corner
Newman and Holyman quoted that
information security is often treated
solely as a technology issue when it
should also be treated as a governance
issue reading this case study helped
Kevin understand the importance of
information security governance and risk
management
let us now look at the first topic goals
mission and objectives of organization
in order to protect an organization's
assets it is important to understand
what the organization does and what it
wants to achieve in other words it is
necessary to identify organizational
goals mission and objectives in this
topic we will describe the role and
importance of goals mission and
objectives and also discuss how to align
information security with the goals the
mission and the objectives of an
organization let us begin with the goals
mission and objectives of an
organization goals mission and
objectives are statements that define
what the organization desires to achieve
they also indicate how the organization
intends to achieve them these statements
help organizations create long term and
short term strategies once goals mission
and objectives have been identified it
becomes easier to align information
security to organizational goals and
protect organizational assets
information security can be aligned with
organizational goals mission and
objectives by reducing the risk posed by
information security threats and with
senior management support as a security
professional in an organization you will
be directly responsible for minimizing
and managing risk through appropriate
activities and controls you must have a
thorough knowledge of the organization's
IT assets as well as its goals mission
and objectives influencing and
organization's core activities requires
the support of senior management this
support comes in the form of priorities
and resources that permit security
professionals to be closely involved
with key activities
as an organization nutri World Inc would
like to focus on improving the security
of communication channels in this
financial year to achieve this goal the
general manager of IT security Kilda
Jacob announced in her recent address to
the team that all security
administrators and IT analyst in the IT
security division need to complete the
CISSP certification Kevin Butler is a
security administrator and the network
firewalls division at nutri worldwide he
is preparing for his CISSP exam he has
understood the importance of mission
goals and objectives of organization and
the importance of aligning its security
to it he read this statement on the
company website nutri worldwide will
pursue and foster opportunities for
growth and enrichment for its employees
and stakeholders with the customer being
the focal point is this statement a
mission goal or objective statement this
is a mission statement mission statement
is a statement of the purpose of an
organization company or person and its
reason for existence it guides the
actions of the company tells its overall
goal provides a path and guides
management and decision making
let us proceed to the next topic
information security management this
topic information security management
describes the controls and organization
implements to manage risk in this topic
we will look at some important
definitions learn about information
security governance and describe
security controls organizational
processes and service level agreements
we will also discuss how to manage third
party governance and learn about privacy
requirements and compliance governance
ensures that security strategies are
aligned with business objectives and are
consistent with regulations the IT
governance Institute defines security
governance as security governance is the
set of responsibilities and practices
exercised by the board and executive
management with the goal of providing
strategic direction ensuring that
objectives are achieved ascertaining
that risks are managed appropriately and
verify that the enterprise is resources
are used responsibly in other words
strategy objectives and risks are
developed and executed in a top-down
manner in a governance model the
executive management is in control of
the activities intended to protect
organizational assets from threats
governance is intended to guarantee that
appropriate information security
activities are being performed to ensure
that risks are reduced in information
security investments are appropriately
directed it also ensures that the
executive management has visibility of
the program and improving the
effectiveness of the program we will
learn about security controls in the
following screen
security controls are measures taken the
safeguard and information system from
attacks against the confidentiality
integrity and availability of the
information system the common term of
confidentiality integrity and
availability is CIA
note that the terms safeguard and
countermeasure are sometimes used as
synonyms for security control security
controls are selected and applied based
on a risk assessment of the information
system
the risk assessment process identifies
system threats and vulnerabilities and
then security controls are selected to
reduce or mitigate the risk there are
three types of security controls they
are administrative security controls
technical security controls and physical
security controls let us look at each
type in the following screen
service level agreements or SLA is a
formally defined level of service
provided by an organization within the
context of security management SLA s may
be defined for many activities including
security incident response a security
team may be required to mobilize within
a stipulated period of time when a
security incident has been called
security alert delivery security alerts
which may be bulletins of threats or
vulnerabilities may need to be delivered
to recipients within a stipulated period
of time security investigation a
security investigator may be required to
respond to a call for assistance within
a stipulated period of time policy and
procedure review a security team may be
required to periodically review policies
procedures and other documents SLA s can
be defined for other tactical activities
performed by security management and
staff the next screen will focus on
managing third party governance
outsourcing is the sub contracting of a
business process to a third-party
company organizations outsource
different functions for many reasons
including redirecting energy on the
organization's core competencies and
controlling the efficient use of capital
and other resources there are some
information security risks associated
with the outsourcing of business process
to third parties including a loss of
control of confidential information
accountability and compliance let us
look at each of these now loss of
control of confidential information an
organization will have to equip the
outsourcer with the information required
to perform its functions efficiently
since this information is now out of the
organization's direct control protection
of that information is now entirely
dependent upon the outsourcers actions
accountability while the organization
has outsourced functions to a third
party and is at the complete mercy of
the third parties integrity the
organization is still completely
accountable for the actions performed by
the outsourcer compliance the risks
identified can also result in compliance
risks regulators hold outsourcers
accountable and not the third party for
ensuring compliance
outsourcing IT support desktop support
and infrastructure is relatively common
and an increasing number of
organizations are investing in
outsourcing ecommerce systems data
center hosting and software and
application development the security of
the outsourced data is of prime
importance to the organization's secure
outsourcing can be achieved by periodic
on-site assessments document exchange
and document reviews and policy and
process reviews let us look at each of
these now on-site assessment of IT
governance includes a review of all the
formal and ad-hoc IT governance
mechanisms and interviews of key
business and IT personnel document
exchange and document review a proper
document management should be in place
so as to secure and control the
documentation flow to the third-party
users must also be able to regulate the
access to documents and ensure that
others can't alter them a regular policy
and process review will help the
organization create an efficient and
secure environment in the next screen we
will learn about the privacy
requirements and compliance
outsourcing is using a third party to
provide information technology support
services that were previously performed
in-house offshoring is outsourcing to
another country offshoring can increase
privacy and regulatory issues let us
look at an example to understand this
for a US medical transcription
organizations data offshore to India
there is no Health Insurance Portability
and Accountability Act HIPAA
certification which is the major
regulation covering healthcare data in
the United States a thorough and
accurate risk analysis must be performed
before outsourcing or offshoring
sensitive data if the data will reside
in another country it is important to
ensure that the laws and regulations
governing it are thoroughly followed
even beyond the country's jurisdiction a
good contract ensures that regulations
and laws governing privacy are followed
even beyond the country's jurisdiction
in the example we looked at already the
Indian company to which the US medical
transcription organization's data was
offshore to can agree to follow HIPAA
via contract as part of the preparation
for the CISSP exam Kevin is studying the
importance of the information security
governance and management while doing so
he lists out the distinguishing points
about governance and management to
ensure he understands the difference
between the two governance is associated
with providing an oversight enacting
policies establishing accountability
resources planning and strategic
planning management on the other hand
involves implementation enforcement of
policies handling responsibilities
resource planning and project planning
based on his observations
Kevin concluded that doing the right
thing is management and doing things
right is governance is this statement
true it is not true the correct
statement would be doing the right thing
is governance and doing things right is
management
let us now look at the next topic the
big three CIA the core principles of
information security are confidentiality
integrity and availability often called
as CIA all other concepts and activities
in information security are based on
these principles in this topic we will
look at the role in importance of CIA in
information security management we will
also discuss confidentiality integrity
and availability in detail let us
understand the role and importance of
CIA and information security management
the three components of the CI a
triangle are confidentiality integrity
and availability they have served as the
industry standard for computer security
since the time of the first mainframes
these three concepts are a great
foundation for the dynamic world of
information technology they are
responsible for the development of
several new key components in the
expanded CIA triangle organizations look
up to these basic components as the
building blocks to information security
confidentiality integrity and
availability are the foundation for
information security CIA forms the basis
on which the information security is
built confidentiality integrity and
availability work together to provide
assurance that systems and data remain
secure every part of CIA triad is
equally important depending on the data
and IT resource different prioritization
of the three will be required in the
next screen we will learn about
confidentiality
the principle of confidentiality asserts
that information and functions can be
accessed only by authorized parties
private information about citizens has
resulted in the proliferation of
information systems operated by both
government and industry typically a
personal profile containing many items
of basic information are established
when an individual begins a relationship
with an organization this relationship
is started when a person makes a
purchase registers to vote renews a
driver's license pays taxes or consults
a position even if the purpose or the
duration of the relationship is brief
often the information will remain on the
organization's information systems for
an extended period often for many years
individuals expect that their
confidential information will not be
disclosed to unauthorized parties and
that it will be properly protected
however some organizations may not
handle the information properly
resulting in an unauthorized disclosure
this could result in an attempted
identity theft or financial fraud
carried out against the persons whose
information was compromised military
secrets which are highly confidential
information can be taken as an example
here military secrets can be accessed
only by authorized personnel threats to
confidentiality are from many sources
hackers and master raiders compromise
the confidentiality of the data any
unauthorized user activity can also
compromise the confidentiality of
information other threats to
confidentiality are unprotected
downloaded files unprotected networks
and unauthorized programs like trojan
horses and viruses social engineering
attack which uses social skills to
obtain information is another threat the
next screen will focus on integrity
the principle of integrity asserts that
information and functions can be added
altered or removed only by authorized
people and means integrity is achieved
through a role based access control
which is the generic name for a
mechanism that controls the actions
performed by individuals information may
be stored in the database of tables
consisting of tables rows and fields the
concept of integrity governs which
individuals are able to modify which
table rows and fields in the database
incorrect data entered by the user into
a database can be taken as an example
here in data security the need for
integrity encompasses software systems
and the people who design build and
operate them software must operate
properly
particularly when a program is accessing
and modifying data systems must be
properly configured so that the data
that resides on them is managed and
updated correctly the people who design
build and operate software and systems
must be properly trained on the
technologies that they are using and
they must adhere to a code of
professional ethics that guides their
behavior and decision making similar to
the confidentiality the threats to
integrity come from hackers masqueraders
unauthorized user activity unprotected
downloaded files networks and
unauthorized programs like trojan horses
and viruses authorized users can also
corrupt the data and programs
accidentally or intentionally next we
will discuss availability in detail
the principle of availability a search
that systems functions and data must be
available on-demand according to
agreed-upon parameters based on levels
of service in other words systems should
be available and in function a good
example for availability would be
network load balancing availability is
multifaceted and involves separate
safeguards and mechanisms to ensure that
systems and data are available when
needed these safeguards range from
firewalls and antivirus software to
resilient architectures for disaster
recovery planning availability covers
nearly all the aspects of data security
that directly or indirectly protects a
system from any harm
threats to availability are denial of
service and distributed denial of
service attacks natural disasters like
fires floods storms or earthquakes
availability can also be disturbed by
human actions like bombs or strike
let us proceed to the next topic
information classification information
of different types must be secured in
different ways therefore a
classification system is needed whereby
the information is classified a policy
is laid down on how to handle
information according to its class and
security mechanisms are enforced on
systems approach to handling the
information in this topic we will look
at the need for information
classification its objectives government
or military sector classification
commercial or private sector
classification information
classification criteria and the layers
of responsibility this screen describes
the need for information classification
there are several good reasons to
classify information not all data has
the same value to an organization some
data is valuable to the people who take
strategic decisions because it aids them
in taking long term or short term
business direction decisions some data
such as trade secrets formulas and new
product information is so valuable that
its loss could create a significant
problem for the enterprise in the market
place this could create public
embarrassment by causing a lack of
credibility for these reasons it is
obvious that information classification
has a higher enterprise level benefit
information can have an impact on a
business globally apart from the
business unit or line operation levels
its primary purpose is to enhance
confidentiality integrity and
availability and to minimize the risk to
the information in addition by focusing
the protection mechanisms and controls
on the information areas that need it
the most you achieve an efficient cost
to benefit ratio cost of benefit ratio
aims at generating maximum benefits from
the available resources and budget
the objectives of information
classification are discussed in this
screen the objective of an information
classification scheme varies from sector
to sector in general the information
classification is done to minimize risks
on sensitive information information
classification has the longest history
in the government or military sectors in
these sectors information classification
is used primarily to prevent the
unauthorized disclosure of information
and the resultant failure of
confidentiality a commercial or private
sector company might wish to employ
classification to maintain a competitive
edge in a tough marketplace there might
also be other sound legal reasons for a
company to employ information
classification such as to minimize
liability or to protect valuable
business information information
classification can also be employed to
comply with privacy laws or to enable
regulatory compliance
the government or military sector
classification is described in this
screen the information classification
scheme followed by the government or
military sector has five levels top
secret secret confidential sensitive but
unclassified or SBU and unclassified top
secret is the highest level of
information classification the
unauthorized disclosure of top-secret
information will cause exceptionally
severe damage to the country's national
security the next level is secret this
is the information designated to be of a
secret nature the unauthorized
disclosure of this information could
cause some damage to the country's
national security the third level is
confidential this is the information
designed to be of a confidential nature
the unauthorized disclosure of this
information may cause damage to the
country's national security this level
applies to the documents labeled between
sensitive but unclassified and secret in
sensitivity the fourth level is
sensitive but unclassified this is the
information designated as a minor secret
that may not create serious damage to
the country's national security if
disclosed however such material would
cause undesirable effects if they are
available in public the lowest level is
unclassified this is the information
designated as neither sensitive nor
classified the public release of this
information does not violate the
confidentiality of a country's national
security
we will discuss commercial or private
sector classification in this screen the
information classification scheme
followed by the commercial or private
establishments has four levels
confidential private sensitive and
public the highest level is confidential
this classification applies to the
sensitive business information that is
intended strictly for use within the
organization
the unauthorized disclosure of such
information can seriously and adversely
affect the organization its stockholders
business partners or customers for
example information about new product
development trade secrets and merger
negotiations is considered confidential
the next level is private this
classification applies to the personal
information that is intended for use
within the organization the unauthorized
disclosure of such information can
seriously add adversely affect the
organization or its employees for
example medical information and salary
levels are considered private the third
level is sensitive information that
requires a higher level of
classification than normal data can be
termed as sensitive an optimized
disclosure of this information could
affect the company this information is
protected from a loss of confidentiality
as well as from a loss of integrity due
to an unauthorized alteration this
information requires a higher than
normal assurance of accuracy and
completeness the lowest level is public
this is similar to unclassified
information all of a company's
information that does not fit into any
of the other categories can be
considered public while its unauthorized
disclosure may be against policy it is
not expected to affect the organization
its employees or its customers
neither seriously nor adversely
vacation criteria will be discussed in
this screen once the scheme is decided
upon the government agency or the
company must develop the criteria to
decide what information goes into which
classification as seen in the image
several criteria may be used to
determine the classification of an
information object like conditions
elements limitations and procedures
classification can be decided based on
certain conditions which the information
satisfies such as value age useful life
and personal associations value is the
commonly used criteria for classifying
the data in private sector if the
information is valuable to an
organization or its competitors it needs
to be classified age states that the
classification of information might be
lured if the informations value
decreases over time useful life states
that if the information has been made
obsolete due to new information
substantial changes in the company or
other reasons the information can often
be declassified if information is
personally associated with specific
individuals or is addressed by a privacy
law it might need to be classified for
example investigative information that
reveals informant names might need to
remain classified while implementing
information classification you will need
to consider and implement appropriate
practices related to its authorization
custody reproduction logging labeling
filing etc you must also take into
account certain limitations like ability
of expert death except Estonian and
incompatible activities of the
administrator while classifying the
information you also need to specify
certain procedures like controlling the
use of information and labeling of
information
kevin has understood the importance of
information its criticality to accompany
and importance of assigning a value to
it Network firewalls division has a lot
of information that is created and
maintained
however Kevin recognizes not all the
information is critical he would like to
do a high level classification on the
information accessible to him what are
the different information classification
levels Kevin would need to use the
information classification levels for
any commercial organization are
confidential private sensitive and
public let us proceed to the next topic
security policy implementation security
policies are the foundation for sound
security implementation often
organizations will implement technical
security solutions without first
creating this foundation of policies
standards guidelines and procedures
thus unintentionally creating unfocused
and ineffective security controls in
this topic we will discuss the security
policies and its types we will also look
at security policy implementation policy
chart along with the standards
guidelines procedures and baselines
security policy can be defined as an
overall general statement produced by
senior management or a selected policy
board or committee that dictates the
role of security within the organization
building a good security policy lays
foundation for the successful
implementation of security related
projects in the future this is an
important measure to reduce the risk of
unacceptable use of any of the company's
information resources the first step
towards enhancing a company's security
is the introduction of a precise yet
enforceable security policy informing
staff on the various aspects of their
responsibilities general use of company
resources and explaining how to handle
sensitive information the policy will
also describe the meaning of acceptable
use as well as lists prohibited
activities an effective policy should be
generic non-technical and easily
understood by everyone it should provide
a mission statement for security and
should represent the business objectives
it should be developed to integrate
security into all business functions and
processes as the company changes over a
period the security policy should be
reviewed and modified accordingly like
any other important document it is very
essential that it should be dated in
version controlled finally the policy
should be forward-thinking which means
it should support vision and mission of
the organization types of security
policies will be covered in the next
screen
a strategic goal can be viewed as the
ultimate end point while tactical goals
are the steps necessary to achieve it
general security policies are derived
from laws regulations and requirements
the functional implementation policies
are subsets of general organizational
policy a policy is implemented using
standards guidelines procedures and
baselines as shown in the flowchart
standards guidelines procedures and
baselines are the tactical tools used to
achieve and support the directives in
the security policy which is considered
the strategic goal as you can see from
the policy hierarchy chart and figure
policies are considered the first and
highest level of documentation from
which the lower level elements of
standards procedures baselines and
guidelines flow however this order does
not mean that the policies are more
important than the lower elements these
higher level policies which are the
general policies and statements should
be created first in the process for
strategic reasons and then the tactical
elements can follow we will discuss
these tactical tools in the next screen
kevin was examining a security policy of
nutri worldwide Inc that was introduced
a decade ago and turned out to be a bad
example this policy was withdrawn within
a month after its launch during his
examination of the policy he identified
that it covered elements of a good
security policy like purpose objective
responsibilities compliance and review
which important element of the policy is
missing from the list Kevin identified
scope is the missing element in the
policy let us proceed to the next topic
information risk management information
risk management focuses on finding the
level of risk associated with a given
activity or asset and how to handle it
in this topic we will look at the
security definitions and discuss
information risk management or IRM and
detail
information risk management or IRM is
the process of identifying and assessing
the risk reducing it to an acceptable
level and implementing the right
mechanisms to maintain that level risk
management process involves establishing
the context identifying the risks
analyzing the risks evaluating the risks
and finally treating the risks the risk
management process minimizes the impact
of threats realized and provides a
foundation for effective management
decision-making this process can be
understood better if you answer the
following questions what could happen
that is the threat event if it happened
how bad could it be that is the threat
impact how often could it happen that is
the threat frequency is it annualized
how certain are the answers to the first
three questions that is recognition of
the uncertainty what can be done that is
risk mitigation how much will it cost
that is the annualized cost is it cost
effective that is cost-benefit analysis
while studying the information risk
management process Kevin made notes on
the security definitions based on
examples from his day-to-day work as
follows asset can be servers and systems
of company a good example he identified
for vulnerability is a weak rule set for
the firewall a good example he
identified for a threat is hacking of
networker servers a good example he
identified for a threat agent is a
hacker a good example he identified for
at risk is the loss of critical
organization data a good example he
identified for exposure is an instance
of 25% loss of data which is unencrypted
based on the definitions he would like
to define the purpose and role of the
risk management process what will the
risk management process achieve it helps
maintain the identified risks to an
acceptable level
while studying the information risk
management process Kevin made notes on
the security definitions based on
examples from his day-to-day work as
follows asset can be servers and systems
of company a good example he identified
for vulnerability is a weak rule set for
the firewall a good example he
identified for a threat is hacking of
networker servers a good example he
identified for a threat agent is a
hacker a good example he identified for
at risk is the loss of critical
organization data a good example he
identified for exposure is an instance
of 25% loss of data which is unencrypted
based on the definitions he would like
to define the purpose and role of the
risk management process what will the
risk management process achieve it helps
maintain the identified risks to annex
let us move on to the next topic risk
analysis risk analysis is a method of
identifying vulnerabilities and threats
and assessing the possible damage to
determine where to implement security
safeguards in this topic we will learn
about risk analysis and discuss its
goals we will also look at the risk
analysis team steps for risk analysis
information and assets valuation and
types of risk analysis then we will take
a look at the steps for quantitative
risk analysis and understand qualitative
risk analysis with examples we will also
compare quantitative and qualitative
risk analysis finally we will learn
about countermeasure selection and
handling risk
let us begin with risk analysis in this
screen risk analysis can be defined as
the analysis of the probability and
consequences of each known risk some of
the significant roles of risk analysis
are discussed here risk analysis helps
in prioritizing the organizational risks
and calculates the cost of safeguards to
protect against those risks it provides
a cost-benefit comparison between the
cost of safeguards and the potential
cost of loss a safeguard is implemented
only when the cost of loss exceeds the
cost of safeguard it helps in
identifying and prioritizing the risk
factors with greater impact the priority
level of the risk is determined by
combining estimates of probability and
consequences risk analysis also helps in
integrating the security program
objectives with the organization's
business objectives and requirements it
also helps the company to draft a
suitable budget for a security program
and it's essential security components
the next screen will focus on goals of
risk analysis
the goals of risk analysis are discussed
in detail in this screen risk analysis
mainly has four goals it helps the
organisation in identifying its assets
and their values it helps in identifying
the vulnerabilities and threats it helps
to measure the possibility and impact of
these latent threats it helps in
providing an economic balance between
the cost of the countermeasure
and the impact of the threat for
effective risk analysis an organization
needs to form a risk analysis team a
risk analysis team consists of
individuals from many or all departments
it is to ensure that all the threats are
identified and addressed the team
members may be part of management
application programmers IT staff systems
integrators operational managers and any
key personnel from key areas of the
organization the information risk
management team leader or risk manager
acts as a liaison between the team and
executive management further risk
management team may consist of risk
manager system or network administrator
system business owner system technical
owner executive sponsor information
security officer the next screen focuses
on steps for risk analysis
to perform risk analysis a company first
decides what assets must be protected
and to what extent this step is called
as asset and information value
assignment it also indicates the amount
of money that can go towards protecting
specific assets next it must evaluate
the functionality of the available
safeguards and determine which ones
would be most beneficial for the
environment this step is called as risk
analysis and assessment finally the
company needs to appraise and compare
the cost of the safeguards these steps
and the resulting information enable
management to make the most intelligent
and informed decisions about selecting
and purchasing countermeasures this step
is called as countermeasure selection
and implementation let us proceed to the
next screen to understand information
and assets valuation understanding the
value of an asset is the first step to
understand what security mechanisms
should be put in place and what funds
should go towards protecting it assets
may be tangible like computers
facilities supplies or it can be
intangible like reputation data and
intellectual property it is usually
harder to quantify the values of
intangible assets which may change over
time the value of an asset should
reflect on all the identifiable cost
that would arise if there were an actual
impairment of the asset the following
issues should be considered when
assigning values to assets cost to
acquire or develop the asset cost to
maintain and protect the asset value of
the asset to owners and users value of
the asset to adversaries value of
intellectual property that went into
developing the information price others
are willing to pay for the asset cost to
replace the asset if lost or damaged
operational and production activities
that are affected if the asset is
unavailable liability issues if the
asset is compromised usefulness and role
of the asset in the organization let us
look at the types of risk analysis in
the following screen
there are two types of approaches to
risk analysis quantitative and
qualitative quantitative analysis uses
risk calculations that attempt to
predict the level of monetary losses and
the percentage of chance for each type
of threat quantitative is more objective
qualitative analysis does not use
calculations but it's more situation and
scenario based qualitative is more
subjective qualitative analysis does not
assign numbers in monetary values to
components and losses instead
qualitative methods walk through
different scenarios of risk
possibilities and rank the seriousness
of the threats and the validity of
different possible countermeasures based
on opinions let's go through the steps
to perform a quantitative risk analysis
in this screen quantitative risk
analysis requires certain parameters to
be calculated for estimating risk these
parameters include SLE EF a ro and a le
single loss expectancy or SLE is a
dollar amount that is assigned to a
single event that represents the
company's potential loss amount if a
specific threat were to take place it
represents an organization's loss from a
single threat and is derived from the
following formula single loss expectancy
equals asset value in dollars multiplied
by exposure factor in percentage where
exposure factor or EF represents the
percentage of loss that a realized
threat could have on a certain asset SLE
is primarily defined to create the
annualized loss expectancy a le it is
occasionally used by itself to describe
a disastrous event for a business impact
assessment BIA business impact analysis
BIA predicts the consequences of
disruption of a business function and/or
a business process annualized loss
expectancy or a le is the annually
expected financial loss to an
organization from a threat the a le
value dictates if the company has to
bring in controls or safeguards to
protect the asset from the threat a le
can be derived from the following
formula annualized loss expectancy
equals single loss expectancy multiplied
by annualized rate of occurrence where
annualized rate of occurrence or aro is
the value that represents the estimated
frequency of a specific threat taking
place within the time frame of one year
let us consider an example of fire
destroying a server with the data
encrypted in asset value of $6,000 the
exposure factor is 50% and the chances
of fire in one year is 10% which is the
annualized rate of occurrence using the
given conditions first let us calculate
the single loss expectancy SLE equals
$6,000 multiplied by 50% which is $3,000
now let us calculate the annual loss
expectancy a le equals 10 percent
multiplied by three thousand dollars
which is $300
let us learn about qualitative risk
analysis in this screen qualitative
analysis techniques include judgment
best practices intuition and experience
examples of qualitative techniques to
gather data are Delphi brainstorming
storyboarding focus groups surveys
questionnaires checklists one-on-one
meetings and interviews the risk
analysis team will determine the best
technique for the threats that need to
be assessed as well as the culture of
the company and individuals involved
with the analysis the table on the
screen lists a few threats the
probability impact and the corresponding
countermeasures put into place the
threat probability and the impact are
given different ratings like high medium
and low based on some assumptions for
example although the probability of fire
is low when it occurs it has a high
impact on the organization
countermeasure for this threat is a fire
extinguisher some War examples are given
in the table in the following screen let
us look at some examples of qualitative
analysis
delphi technique is the most important
qualitative technique from the point of
view of the exam it is a group decision
method used to ensure that each member
gives an honest opinion of what he or
she thinks the result of a particular
threat will be this avoids a group of
individuals feeling pressured to go
along with others thought processes and
enables them to participate in an
independent and anonymous way Delphi
technique has two methods consensus
Delphi and modified Delphi method the
first method is the consensus Delphi
method in which experts help to identify
the highest priority security issues and
corresponding countermeasures this is a
systematic interactive forecasting
method based on independent inputs of
selected experts the other method is
modified Delphi method which is a silent
form of brainstorming in which the
participants develop ideas individually
and silently with no group interaction
the ideas are submitted to a group of
decision makers for consideration and
action
the risk analysis team management risk
analysis tools and culture of the
company will dictate which approach
whether quantitative or qualitative risk
analysis will be used the goal of both
approaches is to estimate a company's
real risk and to rank the severity of
the threats so the correct
countermeasures can be put into place
within a practical budget each method
has its merits and the merits some of
which are outlined in the given table
for the purpose of comparison
a security countermeasure also called a
safeguard must make good business sense
that is it is cost-effective and its
benefit is greater than its cost this
requires another type of analysis called
a cost-benefit analysis a commonly used
cost-benefit calculation for a given
safeguard is a le before implementing
safeguard - a le after implementing
safeguard - annual cost of safeguard
equals value of safeguard to the company
for example if the a le of the threat of
a fire bringing down a web server is
$10,000 prior to implementing the
suggested safeguard and the a le is two
thousand dollars after implementing the
safeguard while the annual cost of
maintenance and operation of the
safeguard is 500 dollars then the value
of this safeguard to the company is
seven thousand five hundred dollars each
year other factors that influence the
selection of countermeasure or safeguard
are TCO
and ROI total cost of ownership or TCO
is the total cost for a mitigating
safeguard return on investment or ROI is
the amount of money saved by
implementing a safeguard the risk
analysts may not always get exact
estimates like in the case of an ROI due
to lack of information and data this may
lead to uncertainty in risk analysis
uncertainty refers to the degree to
which you lack confidence in an estimate
this is expressed as a percentage from
zero to 100% if you have a twenty five
percent confidence level in something it
could be said that you have a seventy
five percent uncertainty level capturing
the degree of uncertainty when carrying
out a risk analysis is important because
it indicates the level of confidence the
team and management should have in the
resulting figures
risk can be treated in four basic ways
transfer it rejected reduce it or accept
it
assigning or transferring the potential
cost of a loss due to risk to another
party such as an insurance company is
called risk transference if a company
decides to terminate the activity that
is foreseen as a risk it is known as
risk avoidance taking measures to alter
or improve the risk position of an asset
throughout the company is risk reduction
accepting the level of loss that will
occur and absorbing the loss is known as
risk acceptance the reason a company
implements countermeasure is to reduce
its overall risk to an acceptable level
however there is always some amount of
risk leftover in any environment this is
known as residual risk residual risk is
different from total risk total risk is
the risk a company faces if it chooses
not to implement any type of safeguard a
company may choose to accept total risk
if the results of cost-benefit analysis
indicate this is the best course of
action there is an important difference
between total risk and residual risk and
which type of risk a company is willing
to accept the following are the
conceptual formulas to calculate total
risk and residual risk total risk equals
threats multiplied by vulnerabilities
multiplied by asset value residual risk
can be derived using two formulas one is
residual risk equals total risk
multiplied by control gaps where a
control gap is the protection that a
countermeasure cannot provide the second
formula is residual risk equals total
risk
- countermeasures
kevin is assigned the task of providing
security solution for finance department
of the organization since he had a very
limited knowledge of financial data he
had to take help of George Carter EVP
finance to put proper controls for the
sensitive financial data he suggested
that a risk analysis team should be
formed with the functional heads of the
organization this team will then carry
out the task of information asset
valuation identifying vulnerabilities
and threats assessing the risks and
recommendations for risk mitigation the
team will prepare a report which is then
presented to the senior management for
review and approval what are the
different types of asset that Kevin asks
this team to classify into all assets
were asked to be classified into
tangible and intangible asset let us
proceed to the next topic managing
personnel security in this topic we will
discuss the importance of managing
personnel security we will look at the
hiring practices and employee
termination procedures we will also
learn about the vendor contractors and
consultant controls and discuss some of
the best work practices the insider
threat is one of the top information
security risks faced by the
organization's the people inside the
organization need access to the data and
resources to complete their assigned
work they have the potential to misuse
these access privileges
hence managing personnel security
becomes an imperative task to any
organization it is important to protect
sensitive information by securely
managing the lifecycle of employment
that is pre-employment during employment
and post employment phases hiring
qualified and trustworthy individuals
always depends upon implementing and
adhering to personnel policies screen
out those individuals whose past actions
may indicate undesirable behavior in the
current organization in the next screen
we will discuss the concept of managing
personnel security
we will now discuss the controls for
vendors contractors and consultants
these controls mostly act as
preventative controls vendors and
temporary employees should be given
limited access to the information a
nondisclosure agreement should be signed
also a thorough background checks should
be done access control should be
properly implemented contractors should
always be escorted within the
organization a proper supervision should
be carried out background checks and
access control should be strictly
implemented consultants must be escorted
whenever they visit your facility a
nondisclosure agreement should be signed
a thorough pre-screening and background
checks should be done access control
should be properly implemented
Kevin recalled the process followed by
nutri worldwide while he was hired when
kevin applied for the job the company
had asked for a detailed resume he had
to pass through three rigorous rounds of
interviews in which his technical skills
educational background criminal history
and his ability to work in a team were
checked he was later offered the job and
on the day of joining he had the signed
non-disclosure agreement since he was
about to handle some critical
infrastructure of the company Kevin now
understands the importance of employee
hiring and termination policies and how
it directly affects the information
security posture of any organization
hiring practices employed at the time
Kevin was hired by nutri Worldwide Inc
act is which type of control they are
preventive type controls
some of the best work practices are
described in this screen separation of
duties prescribes that multiple people
are required to complete critical or
sensitive transactions the goal of
separation of duties is to ensure that
in order for someone to be able to abuse
access to sensitive data or transactions
that person must convince another party
to act in mutual agreement job rotation
is good for cross training and also
reduces the likelihood that employees
will collude for personal gain it
provides an organization with the means
to help mitigate the risk associated
with any one individual having too many
privileges rotation of duties simply
requires that one person does not
perform critical functions or
responsibilities without interruption
mandatory vacations can be used to
detect or prevent irregularities that
violate policy and practices it requires
employees to be away from work to help
reveal fraudulent or suspicious behavior
the sheer knowledge that mandatory leave
as a possibility might deter some
individuals from engaging in fraudulent
behavior in the first place because of
the increased likelihood of getting
caught split knowledge so that one
individual only has enough knowledge to
perform a part of a task it focuses on
the uniqueness of separate objects that
must be joined together applying dual
control wherein two or more people must
be available and active to perform an
action dual control has to do with
forcing the collusion of at least two or
more persons to combine their split
knowledge to gain access to an asset
both split knowledge and dual control
complement each other and are necessary
functions that implement the segregation
of duties in high integrity
cryptographic environments
let us proceed to the next topic
security awareness training the
management's directives pertaining to
security are captured in the security
policy and the standards procedures and
guidelines are developed to support
these directives this topic focuses on
the importance of security awareness
training awareness training and
education and also on the security
awareness training implementation
let us discuss the importance of
security awareness training in this
screen security awareness training is an
essential activity which should be
carried out by the organization the
importance of security awareness
training includes security awareness
training helps the organization
understand the importance of security to
the company as a whole and to each
individual it helps users understand the
expected responsibilities and acceptable
behaviors and non-compliance
consequences from an individual's
perspective the security awareness
training is performed to modify
employees behavior and attitude towards
security security awareness training
brings improvement in the overall
security of the organization it helps
the organization to implement controls
in a better way in the next screen we
will learn about security awareness
training awareness training and
education in detail
to achieve the desired result of the
security program the organization's have
to impart various training methods
depending on the requirements for this
purpose security awareness training is
included by organizations security
awareness training uses three methods of
training and they are awareness training
and education
let us discuss awareness the main
objective of awareness programs is to
focus attention of employees on security
through this method the organization's
can inform employees about their roles
and expectations surrounding their roles
in the observance of information
security requirements
let us discuss training the objective of
training is to produce relevant and
needed security skills and competency
the main advantages of using training as
the method our training also helps to
provide guidance surrounding the
performance of particular security or
risk management functions it provides
information on the security and risk
management functions let us discuss
education the main objective of
Education is to integrate all the
security skills as well as competencies
into a common body of knowledge adding a
multidisciplinary study of concepts
issues and principles the major
advantage of this method of training is
that the educated employees can aid the
organization and fulfilling security
program objectives we will discuss the
implementation of the security awareness
training in the following screen
for an organization to achieve the
desired results that security program it
must communicate the what how and why of
security to its employees the table
represents the steps to develop and
implement a good security awareness
training program the steps to develop
and implement a good security awareness
training program are identify training
requirements within the organization
example users contracts customers legal
etc establish training objectives such
as indoctrinate system users specify
security requirements effectively relay
information security requirements and to
motivate personnel to comply with the
requirements set training program goals
such as people must be aware of risks
compliance is needed for effective
information protection avoid fraud waste
and abuse education has the long term
impact time frame whereas training has
intermediate and awareness has very
short term impact
let us continue to the next topic
managing security function in this topic
we will discuss the importance of
managing security function we will also
discuss the best practices for managing
security function security program is an
inevitable function of every
organization hence managing the security
function is vital the importance of
managing security function is given
below security function helps in the
evaluation of the effectiveness of the
security program identify deficiencies
and prioritize the things that require
improvement through proper collection
analysis and reporting of the necessary
information managing security function
facilitates decision-making performance
improvement and accountability
well-organized management of the
security function of an organization
will result in the effective and
efficient implementation of security
controls efficient management of the
security function will ensure that the
assets are well protected managing the
security function ensures proper
allocation of budget for security as per
the business requirement
Kevin Butler security administrator
received a mail from Elijah Wyatt head I
T security nutri worldwide informing him
that he has been selected to undergo
training on the latest version of the
firewall which he was handling Kevin is
excited about the training as that would
further enhance his skills since the
security program is an ongoing activity
the management is eager to improve its
effectiveness so that the security
incidences are maintained at lowest
level proper budget and resources are
allocated to help maintain the security
posture of the organization what is the
most important requirement for
effectively managing the security
function the support of senior
management is the most important
requirement for effectively managing the
security function let us summarize the
topics covered in this domain the
organization security program should be
aligned with the organization's goals
mission and objectives information
security governance provides strategic
direction and ensures security
objectives are achieved risk management
helps an organization ensure that an
organization properly identifies
analyzes and mitigates risk when
choosing the right safeguard to reduce a
specific risk the cost functionality and
effectiveness must be evaluated and a
cost-benefit analysis must be performed
security policy guides the security
program in the organization standards
guidelines baseline and procedures are
required to implement the security
program security awareness training and
education help the employees to upgrade
their knowledge of security and also
help improve the overall security
posture of the company
in the next lesson we will learn about
access control in detail